アイスホッケーをしていました今年の8月
に
選手を引退して今はスケート教室だったり
とかメディアを通してたくさんの人に
愛想家を知ってもらうような活動をしてい
ますこんな
スポーツをしていました
すごくスピードがあって
迫力もあってとても面白いスポーツなん
ですこのスポーツの
魅力にどっぷりとハマって
競技を続けてきましたで私はじめたのは6
歳の時ですこれ父親と一緒にスケート始め
た頃に移ってる写真なんですけど
後ろに
ビルとか
映ってるの見えますかね
これ小学校の
校庭に
リンクがあってそこで撮った写真なので
後ろに
ビルが映っています私苫小牧の出身なん
ですけどこういうふうに冬になると
工程にリンクができますここで
冬になると体育の授業です系統をしたりと
かあと仲休み昼休みに
自由にスケートを滑れるそんな環境でした
なので私たち苫小牧出身の人たちは小学校
に上がる前に
各自スケート準備するんですね私も父と母
と一緒に
スケート買いに行きましたそこで
父と母から
フィギュアスケートとアイスホッケーの
スケートどっちがいいですかっていうのを
聞かれました私は
女の子フィギュアスケートっていう
イメージだったので
フィギュアっていうふうに即答したんです
よそして父と母から
ホッケーのスケートを選ばないってことは
ホッケーやらないってことでいいよねOK
途中でやりたいって言ってもすぐには
スケートは買い換えられないよっていう
こと
言われましたで5歳の私すごく考えました
もし
途中でホッケーをやりたいって言ったら
あの時言ったやつじゃんって絶対怒られる
やつだなと思って
念のため
ホッケーの
スケートを選ぶのがベランダだなと思って
それでアイスホッケーのスケートを選び
ましたで結局そのままアイスケを始める
ことになりました
父と母も別に
故郷やってほしくてそうやって言ったわけ
ではないと思うんですよ
買い換えられないから慎重に選んでねって
いう意味で言ったと思うんですけど
ちょっと
誘導尋問されてるなと思ったりしてますで
もそこから25年間アイスホッケー選手と
して
オリンピックにも出ることができましたし
たくさんの経験をさせてもらいました今
ここにいるのも
ホッケーをしていたからだと思うので
誘導尋問してくれた父と母にも今はとても
感謝をしています
でこの25年間の中で私が
積み重ねてきたことが2つあります
1つ目が
トレーニングです
スポーツ選手なので
トレーニングを積み重ねるっていうのは
簡単に
想像できるのかなと思います
想像通りです
めちゃくちゃゴリゴリに
トレーニングしてました
100キロの
重りを
担いだり
持ち上げたり
喘息力で
走ったりとにかく
陸でも
氷の上でも
トレーニングをしていた毎日です
今年の2月の
北京オリンピックまで私は現役選手として
プレーをしてたのでそこまで本当に日常的
にトレーニングがあって
当たり前に
トレーニングと一緒に過ごしている日々
だったんですけど
引退をしてみて
日常生活の中で100キロの森持つこと
ないんだとか
喘息力で走ることないんだなっていうのを
最近
気づき始めましたちょっと非日常的な生活
をしていたんだなというのを最近感じ始め
たところなんですけど
スポーツ選手としては
トレーニングを積み重ね
るっていうのはすごく大切な積み重ねで
必要な
積み重ねだったなというふうに思ってい
ます
もう一つ私が
積み重ねてきたことが
自分を知るということです
自分がどんなプレイヤーなのかどうやって
チームに貢献ができるのかその
後継するために何をすべきなのかこれを
見つけるために
自分を知るという積み重ねをしてきました
私の場合の何をすべきかは
スピードを
極め続けるということでした
自分が
スピードのあるプレイヤーで
スピードを生かしたプレーでチームに貢献
できるということを知ってそのために
すべきことが
スピードを極め続けるということでした
私が
自分がスピードがあるということに気づい
たのは小学校高学年の時でした
でどういうふうに気づいたかというと
すごく
単純で
みんなで
競争をした時に
気づきました
一人で走っていてもなかなか
自分のスピードっていうのは
気づけないことだと思うんです
もし自分が早いと思っててもそれは本当に
カメみたいに遅いスピードかもしれない
でも1列に全員並んでよーいどんで走った
時に
ゴールした時は
誰が一番早いかっていうのは
わかりますよね
そこで私も
自分が早いんだっていうことに
気づきました
何が言いたいかというと
他人を知ることで
自分を知ることができるということです
何事も比較対象があって
初めて
自分の特徴っていうことに気づくことが
できると思います私も一緒に走ってくれた
みんながいたことで
自分のスピードっていう特徴に
気づくことができました
この
担任を知ることで
自分を知ることっていうのは
キャプテンとして
活動をしてきたからこそ
感じてきたところでもあります
私たち女子アイスOKのメンバーは23人
で一つのチームとして
オリンピックに出場します
23人
同じ人間はいないです
それぞれの価値観
考え方
感情いろんなバックグラウンドを持って
いる
選手の集まりです
チームをサポートするのが得意な選手
チームを盛り上げてくれる選手おしゃべり
がすごく得意な選手逆にちょっと苦手な
選手
チームを分析してくれる選手いろんな
タイプの
選手がいますそのいろんなタイプがの選手
がいることを知っていく中で私も
私は
みんなのことをまとめるのがちょっと得意
かもしれないとか
みんなの前で話すのが得意かもしれないと
いうことを
気づくことができました
で今私は選手としては
スピードが持ち味
キャプテンとしては
チームまとめることが得意っていう話をし
たんですけど
得意なこととか
秀でてることだけが
特徴になるとは限らないです
例えば
私たち女子23人
全員集まってミーティングをした時に
全員がおしゃべりが得意で
自己主張が得意な選手の集まりだったら
ミーティングは収集がつかないです
ピーチクパーチクピーチクパーチク多分
止まらないですでもそこにおしゃべりが
ちょっと苦手かなって思ってる選手がいる
とその場が調和されたりとかあとはそう
いう選手はたまにしか話さないので
すごく貴重な意見としてチームのみんなが
耳を買った向けます
その選手にとって
自分でちょっと苦手だなって思っている
分野が
チームにとっては
すごく強みになる時もあります
他人との違いを知ってそれを
強み弱みとして
捉えるだけではなくて
他人との違いを
自分にしかできないこと
自分だからできることにどう変換してそれ
を生かしていくかが
重要だと私は思っています
私の場合の
自分にしかできないこと
自分だからできることは
スピードを生かしたプレイで
チームに貢献すること
キャプテンとしては
チームを求めることこれが自分にしかでき
ないことでした
そのためにすべきことが
スピードを極め続けるということでした
選手として必要とされるために
スピードを極め続ける
キャプテンとして
認めてもらうために
スピードを生かしてみんなをまずは
引っ張る
これが私のすべきことでした
この
自分にしかできないこと
自分だからできることそして自分のすべき
ことっていうのが明確になってからは
目標だったり
ゴールに向かって
貫く強さっていうのも
生まれたと思っています
北京オリンピックの1年前のシーズン私は
スウェーデンリーグに所属をしていました
聖霊のチームに所属をしていたんですけど
全く
試合に出ることができませんでした
3シーズン目スウェーデンリーグに所属し
てからは3シーズン目だったんですけど
1-2
シーズン目は普通に試合に出てたんです
けど3シーズン目になって初めて
全く試合に出れない
シーズンがありました
すごく
苦しかったです
オリンピックの1年前のシーズンで全く
試合に出ることができなくって
選手にとっては1年前のシーズンてすごく
大切なシーズンなんですね
コンディションも上げていかなきゃいけ
ない
ゲーム感も作っていかなきゃいけない
そんなシーズンに
全く試合に出ることができなくてこのまま
日本代表に選んでもらえるのか
選んでもらったとしてもしっかり
活躍できるのか
チームのみんなキャプテンとして認めて
くれるのかいろんな
不安が本当に頭をよぎりました
間違いなく25年間の競技人生の中で
すごく苦しかったシーズンだなと思うん
ですけど
私は今まであまりこう
苦しさっていうのを外に出してこなかった
んですけどその時は
本当に多分苦しさから
父と母の前で初めて涙を流しました
私は当時生徒にいたので
対面で会うことはできなかったんですけど
当時宮崎で単身赴任をしていた父親と
地元の苫小牧にいた母親と
スウェーデにいた私の3人で電話をつない
でよく話をしてました
その日も
いつも通りに電話をつないでいってで何気
ない会話の中から
コンディションどうだ
試合どうだっていうこと聞かれましたそう
聞かれた瞬間にもう涙が溢れ出てきて
しまって何も答えることができなかったん
ですね
本当に多分苦しさとストレスが心の中に
溜まっていてでそれぐらい本当に苦しい
苦しい時間だったんですけど
私は涙を流してるの悟られたくなくて
家事をしながら電話とかもしてたのでその
時は
食器洗いをするふりをして水を流しながら
涙は泣いてる音を聞かれないように
電話をつなぎました
父親は
全然気づかなかったんです泣いていること
でも母は一緒に涙を流してくれて大丈夫だ
よって
言ってくれたんですけど
今思い出してもすごくこみ上げてくるもの
があるぐらい本当に苦しかった
シーズンだったんですけど
その中でも
日本代表に
選ばれるために
オリンピックで活躍するために
スピードを極め続けるということを
頑張ろうと思える自分がいましたそれは
自分を知るっていう積み重ねをしてきた中
で
自分の特徴
スピードっていう特徴を知って
自分がどうしたら
チームに貢献できるのかっていうポイント
をしっかりと
自分の中で理解していたから
乗り越えられたことだと思っています
もし自分の中でスピードっていう特徴に
気づかずどうチームに貢献できるかわかっ
ていなかったら
あれもやらなきゃこれもやらなきゃって
いろんなことを頑張りすぎて中途半端な
努力になっていたかもしれないです
逆に
頑張ることがわからなくて
途中で心が折れて挫折をしていたかもしれ
ないです
でも自分の中で明確に何を頑張ればいい
どうしたらチームに貢献できてどうしたら
チームに必要とされてっていうポイントを
しっかりと理解できていてそれが
モチベーション維持につながっていたと
思っています
自分を知るっていう積み重ねをしてきた
からこそ
信じる力だったりとか
貫く力が
生まれたというふうに思っています
今私は
選手引退してアイスホッケーを普及すると
いう活動をしています
選手じゃない立場での私の特徴は
オリンピックにキャプテンとして3回出た
ことだと思っています
オリンピックのユニフォームに
キャプテンマークがついたものを3枚持っ
てるのは日本で私しかいないんです
ちょっと自慢見たくなっちゃったんです
けど私しかいないこの3枚の
ユニフォームを持っている意味っていうの
が
愛想系を普及していくという活動の中で
自分にしかできないことにつながっていく
んじゃないかなというふうに思っています
キャプテンとしての経験をこれからの
活動につなげていきたいなと思っています
選手として
自分にしかできないことを貫いてきたこと
と同じようにこれからの活動の中でも私に
しかできないことを見つけて
突き進んでいきたいなと思っています
きっと皆さんにも
自分にしかできないこと
自分だからできることっていうのはあると
思います
それぞれの夢に向かって
自分にしかできないことを見つけて
突き進んでいけたら最高なんじゃないかな
と思います
ご清聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]